اعلن مكتب ورئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريتش
سوناك اعتزام حكمته تسليما 14 دبابه من
طراز تشالنجر 2 واسلحه ثقيله اخرى الى
اوكرانيا خلال الاسابيع المقبله واوضح
مكتب سوناك عند المملكه المتحده ستشرع في
تدريب قوات اوكرانيه على استخدام هذه
الدبابات والمدفعيه في الايام المقبله
متحدث باسم الحكومه البريطانيه في بيان ان
سوناك ووزراء حكومته سيتحدثون قريبا الى
الحلفاء في جميع انحاء العالم لتكثيف
الضغط على الرئيس الروسي الذي
مستقبل افضل لاوكرانيا وفقا تعبير البيان
في المقابل ردت السفاره الروسيه لدى
بريطانيا بان الدبابات تشارجر اثنين الى
البريطانيه لن تساعد القوات الاوكرانيه في
تغيير الوضع على الارض بل ستصبح هدفا
مشروعا للقوات الروسيه اشارت الى ان ارسال
هذه الدبابات لا يقرب من نهايه الاعمال
القتاليه بل سيسهم في تصعيدها
بارسال الدبابات قتاليه لاوكرانيا اذا
انضم الحلفاء الغربيون الى هذا المسعى من
ساحتها اعلن رئيس الوزراء البولندي
محادثات بشان تسليمه دبابات المانيه الصنع